wie geht's dir du siehst irgendwie ich
hab es ja eben schon ich muss dir hier
noch mal Komplimente machen du siehst
fantastisch entspannt aus danke sehr
geht dir auch so gut
ja g das das war mal das war mal das
immer so junge wenn die Mutter ne wenn
die
Mutter wenn die schon beide Hände nimmt
ne also ins Gesicht so das Gesicht
irgendwie so junge alles in Ordnung dann
dann ne dann denke ich immer so jetzt
muss ich mal überlegen ja das auch ger
oder mit dem früer mit dem mit dem Tuch
dem Taschentuch wenn man Nutella oder
Eis oder
so mache ich jetzt aber bei meinen
Kindern auch meine Mutter kon ich
benutze ja heute noch Nivea Creme also
das ist auch überhaupt keine wermung
sondern ich benutze wirklich seit meiner
Kindheit und meine Mutter konnte das mit
die die Tube oder die Creme mit einer
Hand hat die das hat die mein Gesicht
damit klar gemacht aber das zeht doch
gar nicht doch doch doch die konnte das
ja weil Hal irgendwie so mit der einen
Hand putzen und mit der anderen Hand
schnell den Jungen eincrem so irgendwie
das das konnte die so aber so rum
die Nase den Rest gezogen aber du bist
doch mitten in deiner Promotour hier für
good news on the bad day ich dachte du h
Ränder unter den Augen du bist total
gestesst du kommst hier entspannt
reingeguft das freut mich so zu sehen
dass man so Promotion machen kann ja das
geht
aber das ist schon auch also ich ich
fühle mich eigentlich so wie du gerade
beschrieben hast wie ich aussehen müsste
das ich ganz nett von dir dass du meine
meine meine Horst Tappert Gedächtnis
Augenringe dass du die nicht erwäh oder
zumindestens einfach drüber hinwegst das
Fin ich sehr nett und sehr sehr lüblich
und so
sch aber mir macht das ja auch Spaß ich
glaube das hängt damit zusammen dass ich
wirklich Lust habe das jetzt gerade zu
tun also aber du tust es ja nicht das
erste Mal es ist deine sechste
Studioalbum ja ist es wirklich immer
noch wieder ein anderes Gefühl ist es
neu ist es jedes Mal wieder natürlich
ist jedes Mal also das ist ich weiß
nicht womit man das vergleichen kann
aber es ist halt man hat da was gemacht
über zwei Jahre lang an irgendwas
gearbeitet ob n geschrieben produziert
aufgenommen und jetzt seit drei Monaten
liegt das da mhm und man denkt okay ich
würde jetzt auch gerne dann schon mal
das den Leuten jetzt auch zeigen und so
dann habe ich angefangen das meiner
meiner Mutter mal vorzuspielen Freunden
vorzuspielen mir immer schon mal so ich
konnte halt nicht zurückhalten und habe
immer wie findet ihr das und die fanden
das dann alle gut erschreckenderweise
meine Mutter hat immer irgendwas
auszusetzen gehabt sonst was hatte sie
auszusetzen an diesem Album good news on
B n die sagte mein Junge das ist das
schönste Album dass du je gemacht hast
da kann man alles Lieder kann man so
hören ja aber das ist wenn Eltern den
Freund super finden W W auch schon e
eben darum geht's ja aber dann auch die
meine kredibilen Musiker Freunde die
dann sagen irgendwie so wow tolles
tolles Ding so schöne Lieder und so das
macht mich echt nervös weil ich dann
denke irgendwas stimmt hier nicht moment
du hast so viel Erfolg mit all deinen
anderen Alben gehabt gab's da immer
vorher kritische Stimmen von deinem
befreundeten Umfeld es gab immer
irgendwas gab's zu meckern auf jeden
Fall irgendwas ist nicht rund jetzt sag
keiner B
eben eben eben das ist das ist ja dafür
habe ich ja da deshalb bin ich nervös
okay erstmal Cappuccino weil ich weiß du
bist nervös und Cappuccino beruhigt dich
jaemein oh ja das sehe ich schon das ist
ein starker also das heißt man wird doch
mit jedem neuen Album auch immer ein
bisschen nervös ob man diesen Erfolg
halten kann ja es geht mir da gar nicht
also im im Moment das das war mal so
also wenn man ich die ersten drei
albenum bei mir so sich anguckt dann
habe ich ja sehr wenig geschrieben ich
habe beim ersten Album so gut wie gar
nichts beim zweiten so zwei drei Lieder
beim dritten dann schon so fast die
Hälfte mitgeschrieben und so also ich
habe mich so lang ja ich habe mich so
langsam da so reingefunden auch also
mutiger geworden und natürlich ein
bisschen sicherer auch weil ich halt
dieses Metier Popmusik also selber da
drin stecken hatte ich halt vorher nicht
war ja so eher so Rocker mit so langen
langen Haaren und desal war das ein
bisschen neu jeder hat mal eine
schlechte Phase weißt du ja war eine
schöne war Kranke Kranke wilde Zeit und
so und hat hat Spaß gemacht deshalb muss
ich mich natürlich erstmal mit mit
Popsongs schreiben erstmal ein bisschen
zurechtfinden und hatte damit natürlich
auch auch
Erfolg ich weiß jetzt gar nicht was ich
sagen wollte das Multitasking weiß
Männer ich muss nur ich kann n nicht mal
ein Cappuccino umen und mein Gedanken
dabei weiterführen schlimm ist das
Wahnsinn so jetzt konzentriere ich m
kurz auf
rüen so jetzt jetzt hast die Frage
vergessen kom jetzt weiß ich die
hoffentlich noch weil bei mir ist ja bei
du bist ja nicht Multitasking ich bin ja
schon in meinem Alter fast dem nicht wir
beide hier
versagen ach WE kan nein ze Jahre Erfolg
und und einfach zu wissen eben auch ich
meine jetzt mal wirklich du weißt doch
was deine Fans wollen du musst dich doch
hinsetzen ist doch egal wo du schreibst
am Küchentisch in der Badewanne ne ist
anders du weißt doch du siehst diese
Frauen vor dir und es muss doch fließen
aus der Feder oder so stelle ich mir das
vor bitte korrigi mich sch nee ich will
da gar nicht weißt du was bleib da lass
stell dir das weiterin so V stell das
einfach so vor und und es ist
tatsächlich so Ihr seid mit Sack und
Pack ab nach Dänemark und habt euch da
eingeschlossen und
schön wirklich ja ohne Scherz Sprinter
becklein hinten rein also die
Musikinstrumente und so und dann nach
Dänemark ins puckstudio wir haben auch
in dem Ort wo wir dann waren wo das
puckstudio war die heiligen Hallen die
heiligen Hallen John Elten John die
Gitarre von Faith ist da aufgenommen
worden und depes Mode und depes Mode und
Metallica und noch so ein maelden und
solche Bands also und das macht dich
nicht nervös da das kannst du da dann
reingehen und sagen nicht das war also
es hat was mich nervös gemacht hat waren
die Flecken in den Apartments also es
waren überall also di studio ist seit
gibt's seit den 80ern und es ist genau
seit dem 80ern auch nichts mehr dran
gemacht worden also im Internet sah das
ganz toll aus dieses Studio da haben die
auch gepriesen so mit mit wir haben hier
wir haben Pool und wir haben eine Sauna
und so das war alles gar nicht mehr das
hatten die gar nicht mehr in dem Pool
waren so Sachen drin so Gartenmöbel und
so also das war so
abgeblättertere eklige Sachen nee nee
das es war schon darüber hinaus die eke
Zeit hat dies im Internet dass man sich
da anders verkauft als man dann
tatsächlich ist und das ist gilt
offenbar auch für Hotels aber und das
haben die gemacht also es war ja alles
in einem es war ja so so ein Studio mit
Apartments dazu und die waren wie gesagt
in 80ern gebaut und damals in 80ern
totschick war so alte Ledersofas so
designerkrams bang und Olufsen
Stereoanlage und so aber alles so riesig
und halt uralt und und es waren halt
wirklich überall irgendwelche Flecken
und man hat dann irgendwie haben dann
immer so rätselraden gemacht von wem ist
der wohl ich glaube da hat Lars Ulrich
mal hingekotzt von Metallica ich glaube
der hat da hat das das hat der dahin
kurz und da hat Dave gan mal gelegen mit
seinem fettwiersing also mit seiner sein
pomadenfisur so und dann haben wir uns
so ausgemalt wer das wohl alles war und
was woher die Flecken kamen irgendwann
führte das natürlich sehr weit dass wir
uns schon gar nicht mehr trauten barfus
in dem Haus zu laufen so also eklig mach
du hotelzim barfus laufen oder bist kom
drauf an wenn es Holzboden gibt ja be
Teppich bin ich ein bisschen empfindlich
und machst du Situps auf
hotelzimmerteppich das kann ja manchmal
Lig sein man entdeckt da unterm Bett da
eklige Sachen ja das finde ich komisch
dass sie nie unterm Bett sauber selten
selten einigen Hotels geht das gut wir
wollen ja jetzt hier nicht über die
deutsche Hotellerie reden sondern
bisschen über deine Songs also die du
die Entscheidung noch mal genau die
Single mus nicht nicht dass es schlimmer
wird ja mit dieser Vergesslichkeit nicht
dass du plötzlich auf der Bühne stehst
und dein Text nicht mehr we wenn du
jetzt meine Frag ich hab ist ja das Lied
was ich glaube ich am häufigsten
gesungen habe in meiner Karriere also
bestimmt so eine Millionen Mal Gefüh
und auch das Lied bei dem ich am
häufigsten auch den Text vergesse
wirklich ich war mit meinem Vater dem
habe ich meine Karte geschenkt für Frank
Sinatra auf der Domplatte in Köln und
mein Vater kennt all diese Songs
auswendig und hat uns damit immer GEK
besser als Frank der hte solche monit da
war fast nur noch ein einzelner
Buchstabe und er war hat danach nie
wieder die Platten gespielt weil er das
so schrecklich fand dass Frank seine
eigenen Songs nicht kennt aber wenn es
bei dir auch schon der Fall ist kann ich
immer sagen er kann die Platten wieder
rausholen aber schon immer das ist das
passiert ganz aber Publikum sing doch
mit da machst du kannst du doch einfach
immer Tri tricken kann man natürlich ja
das führt dann s weit D ein ist bei euch
musikan wenn ihr nicht weiter wisst
immer immer Leute hierag rein geht immer
und ich hatte mal die hatten auch schon
mal so Texttafeln dann Fans die das
mitgekriegt haben dass ich mE der
gleichen Stelle Patze haben das dann
aufgeschre mit den Text aufgeschrieben
und dann hingehalten fand ich auch sehr
nett was machst du denn so zwischen zwei
Alben also ich meine du hast gerade
gesagt das fand ich ganz erstaunlich die
Plattenfirma lässt mir Zeit wenn du
sagst du schreibst du hast nicht ein
Abgabetermin dass jetzt sag okay das
letzte Album ist jetzt hier mal zwei
Jahre her jetzt mach mal wieder was
kommt schon mal ja also die Frage oder
so ist ja auch berechtig und dein
Rhythmus ist immer so alle alle zwei ich
glaube alle zwei ist gut weil dann kann
man auch so ein bisschen Abstand nehmen
weil man ist ja mindestens immer ein
Jahr sage ich mal so mit der mit mit mit
auch der der also inklusive Tour dann
zweite dritte Single oder so auch mit
dem Album beschäftigt und so Auftritte
und dann halt ein Jahr noch mal brauchen
zum Schreiben oder überhaupt erstmal
runterfahren und sich überhaupt neu
irgendwie inspirieren lassen das muss ja
auch irgendwo herkommen so also du musst
ja auch Leben damit du über über was
schreiben kannst ja eben du mus die
Leute die immer Geld verdienen Geld
verdien Geld verdien und dann irgendwann
sterben ja genau da haben die über
gelebt genau und haben nicht ein immer
gearbeitet gearbeitet und haben
überhaupt nie gelebt genau also was was
lebst du denn so zwischen der Tour da
musst du dich du musst dich verlieben du
musst ja dich trennen du
musst
mussld ich muss mich
verlieben ich muss ja irgendwas
passieren oder du bist du bist man liest
nichts über dich man hört nichts man
weiß e was du machst wenn du nicht auf
Tour bist oder lese ich das nur nicht
Hamburg Hamburg die Hamburger sind sehr
schweigsam ja ich bin ja auch
norddeutscher also von ich dann da so im
Nachtleben ausug dann kriegt das nicht
sofort jeder mit und so ne ach so ich
habe mich auf dieses Gespräch so ein
bisschen vorbereitet ne und meine
Freundin allefand haben die mir alle
gesagt Sascha der ist immer so nett und
so gut und so und dann habe ich gedacht
kann doch irgendwie nicht sein du bist
immer nett und bist immer gut drauf und
du hast irgendwie keine Sonderwünsche
hier gehabt ich meine guck mal wir
sitzen hier vor diesem tollen
mosaiktisch ja du hast kein Obstteller
bestellt du hast nicht gesagt berbel
wärm die Bank extra an oder schöner
ti ja du es war total unkompliziert und
wirklich sehr sympathisch mit dir hat
Spaß gemacht danke schön und ich wünsche
dir für deine neue ich sag jetzt einfach
Platte ich bleib dabei News in bad times
einfach viel Erfolg
und good news on a bad day einfach viel
erfol danke schön Sasa
tchüs